ma street tacos four four little
spanglers layer translation more street
tacos please and if that's the mood
you're in local chinatown spot mos por
favor has you covered with fusion food
and vibes thanks to cisco who is
sponsoring this segment let's welcome
general manager diane and executive chef
nicole to tell us how we can celebrate
life in general and the holidays with
them now you guys opened up january 2020
yes and then shut down just a few weeks
after because of the pandemic we are
open and we're open for only six weeks
wow shut down after six weeks and we're
shut down
until we reopened back in may
wow so how's it been going since then i
honestly i already know it's a vibe and
it's so much fun because i have all my
friends and we love it there so how's it
been going for you guys well thanks to
our local community yeah we have been
thriving uh we are
the
most favorite speakeasy on campus
we're trying to be humble also
but yeah we are everybody's favorite
taco joint located in the heart of
chinatown i love it um a crazy speakeasy
joint so
uh we love it we're here to announce our
take on jack skellington nightmare
before x-ma yes so we're going to have
some really cool nightmare before xmas
themed cocktails as you guys can see and
then we have chef nicole cooking up our
xmas
um
boot as well so perfect and when does it
start it starts next month so we are
going to be launching it november 30th
oh perfect okay launching it november
30th until december 29th so you have
until a couple days after christmas as
well perfect okay so let's move over to
our chef over here what are you making
girl right now i'm making our lobster
tacos so we had a lot of fun cooking
everything and coming up with dishes
names so i don't know if you're familiar
with the movie but um these are sandy
claws
lobsters that's cute um so
and this is a special menu for the
holidays this is going to be launching
uh just for our our xmos theme so if
everyone really loves it and keeps
coming in asking for it you guys are
going to keep it on the menu
it's fun keep doing new things so y'all
keep coming back okay i love that now
you mentioned earlier speak easy so
explain to everybody what the experience
is like at moscow football so when you
enter our uh restaurant you see just
like our kitchen it's all open windows
so you can actually see our chefs
cooking on the line but then we have a
secret little tunnel that you go back in
vegas and then right in the back is an
amazing experience where you can sit
enjoy drinks live music on certain days
as well
so that is great and your creative
cocktails explain those while we wait
for these tacos so our creative
cocktails the two i have representing us
today is our oogie boogie oh cute so
that is our green cocktail we actually
make a house made uh
pumpkin horchata and that's made with
reposado and then the other cocktail i
have is our sally apple fruit punch oh
that's um so if you're familiar with the
cocktails or the movie and i see little
candy canes in there yeah perfect it's
all themed out for you okay good so this
obviously isn't you know the family
holiday this is the holiday you go to
have fun yes right so let me taste those
tacos all right here you go and tell us
about your happy hour why try these
our happy hour is actually every day
so you can come and enjoy it every day
it's from 3 p.m till 6 p.m we have a
great menu for that as well we actually
just added a couple new things on there
there's some
ceviche on there is that good
girl
this is so good
moss for my
all right let me go to the still now
thank you to cisco for sponsoring this
segment
miles per favor is located on spring
mountain road in chinatown give them a
call at
702-201-1133 or visit moscow
football.com for more information woo
those are good don't forget their
special offer 20 bucket of beer and four
dollar drafts during nfl football of
course and happy hour three to six p.m
daily yes as i am i'll tell you i love
it all right j.c i'll send it to you
that looks so good save me a couple
tacos nope